President Trump announced new efforts to
get crucial supplies like masks gloves
and surgical gowns to medical centers
amid shortages in this country the US
Surgeon General dr. Jerome Adams joins
us from Washington he's a member of the
White House Coronas virus task force dr.
Adams thank you so much for joining us I
know you're hearing a - we are hearing
heartbreaking stories from doctors who
say they cannot get the basics for the
first time we're hearing doctors say I'm
scared I'm scared of leaving my children
without a parent because I could
possibly die doing the job that I love
to do what can you say to these people
today it's no longer good enough to say
we're working on it it's coming help us
on the way you have to help us
understand why this is so difficult and
what you guys are doing right now to
remedy this situation well good morning
and I didn't expect to be starting off
my week with such a dire message for
America but the numbers are going to get
worse this week things are going to get
worse before they get better
and we really need everyone to
understand this is serious to lean into
what they can do to to flatten the curve
and you talked about health care workers
I'm getting those calls every minute of
the day I got calls from people
literally while I was sitting here
waiting to talk to you and I want the
health care workers of America to
understand these are my colleagues these
are my friends and I will not rest until
you all have the tools you need to keep
ourselves we know everything you've just
said we've all heard this a gazillion
times why is this so difficult and I'm
not going to be disrespectful
no no frustrated not at all and I'll
tell you why it's difficult because the
national stockpile purchases 1/10 of 1%
of all the medical supplies in this
country the rest of it is in the market
and so we're doing a couple of things
and I want people to know the tangible
actions were taking we are using the
stockpile through FEMA which has been
activated to level 1 to send out
supplies than they are we sent out over
2 million
masks there are supplies going out to
the places most at need Washington
California New York we have the military
out on the ground in several of these
places we found out CDC teams to provide
backup we've worked with the American
Society of anise
geologists to identify 70,000
ventilators that are in the O R that can
be converted so supplies are going out
we know that they're not going out fast
enough to keep pace with the demand and
that's why the most important message I
have for America is we are halfway
through our 15 days to stop the spread
we need to turn the spigot off
we can't ventilate we can't ventilate
our way out of this problem we need to
make sure in addition to getting
supplies to people that we're really
focusing on demand and getting people
out of the streets stay at home but dr.
Adams the President signed the defense
production Act he can essentially order
companies to manufacture these supplies
that medical professionals professionals
so desperately need at this point why
isn't the government doing that the
government is using the defense
production act to get people to the
table we've worked with 3m we've worked
with Honeywell they are already at max
production here's the thing people don't
understand you don't need to compel
someone to do something that they are
already doing and so yo every single day
there are people looking and saying do
we need to compel someone to do this
let's make the call okay they're already
at max production they're already
working around the clock and again we
are using the stockpile and FEMA to get
resources out to people who need it
we're finding new and innovative people
who were stepping up and volunteering
like Hanes would have never thought that
Hanes would be able to produce surgical
masks they're producing masks we're
hearing reports of shortages on personal
protective equipment and you're saying
we're already at mass max production
does that mean shortages are just gonna
be the way it is well we know that there
are going to be shortages in some areas
and it's why I actually wrote an op-ed
calling on people to stop elective
surgeries we need to make sure that
supplies are getting to New York to
California to Washington to the places
they need and they can't get there if
people are out somewhere else where they
don't see cases right now doing elective
procedures we want to make sure we're
strategically moving the the personal
protective equipment and supplies to
where it is most needed and that's both
supply and driving down demand dr. I'd
like to ask you about things getting
worse and when we might be able to pull
back on some of these restrictions on
movement the president tweeted recently
we cannot let the Cure be worse than the
problem itself and I think a lot of
people would agree that this economic
shutdown is very painful for people but
a medical perspective realistically is
there any chance at the end of this
15-day period we're just gonna go back
to anything like normal well we know
it's gonna be a while before life gets
back to normal and here's what what I
want America to know we don't want to
wait for 15 days we don't want to wait
another day I'm looking at them driving
in and seeing people out all over the
place getting ready for cherry blossoms
on you you you you look on the news and
you see people still at beaches we don't
have a day to waste and what we need to
do is focus on today this our doctor
right now
doctor how far away from the peak of
this do you think we are because some
people have said it's it's not before
the end of April well when you look at
the China data they were able to hit
their peak and come back down at about
six to eight weeks when you look at the
Italy data they're still going up so we
are somewhere between the two and it's
gonna be up to everyone coming together
to drive down demand to determine
whether our curve bends in the direction
of China in six to eight weeks or
whether it bends towards Italy and
unfortunately we're seeing that New York
it's approaching Italy why because the
numbers that you see if cases reflect
what happened two weeks ago and too many
people are waiting too long to really
take these 15 days to stop the spread
initiative seriously didn't have a 15
days to stop the spread voluntary
restrictions they were much more
draconian than that are you saying we
need more stringent recommendations well
in the United States we have a system of
federalism and the governors are in
charge of determining what's appropriate
to their states here's what I'm saying
and we work we've worked well with with
many of the governors with most of the
governors we need everyone if you
weren't seeing cases right now now's the
time you need to be making sure you're
doing the things so that you don't
become the next New York or the next
Italy all right dr. Jerome Adams thank
you so much for being with us this
morning
and if you're healthy you can still
still get blood all right thanks dr.
Adams